eheleute ok wo fange ich an ich habe vor
gut einer woche ich glaube das war
letzten samstag war das genau drei
verlorene koffer bestellt bei einer also
ich muss das erstmal genauer erklären
glaube ich wenn kein corona ist gibt es
ja so viele touristen oder reisende
überall auf der welt die von da nach
danach darf liegen da umsteigen und da
wiederum stecken und dann noch mal
umsteigen und hin und wieder kommt es
vor dass man seinen koffer verliert und
ihnen einfach nicht wieder findet
natürlich nur in einem von 10.000 fällen
wahrscheinlich aber es kommt vor und
normalerweise gibt es dann so alle zwei
monate glaube ich von lufthansa am
frankfurter flughafen irgendwelche
koffer optionen wo du koffer ersteigern
kannst halt mit inhalt aufgrund von
corona ging das nicht schlecht für alle
aber gut für mich weil da muss ich nicht
bis nach frankfurt fahren und ich habe
drei dieser verlorenen koffer für 1000
euro ersteigert check das machen wir
haben wir samstag 24 stunden geht das
online korruption ballern einfach mal
mit und er sieht auch cool aus der
käufer aktion beendet ja in diesem
koffer der ist 14 kilo schwer
der wirt will deswegen bin ich darauf
bereich nach oben zu gehen man muss
wirklich auf zack sein um hier gute
sachen abzustauben sanktionen beendet
jetzt sicher auch den koffer geschnappt
ich bin wirklich sehr aufgeregt weil in
ihren koffern kann ja alles drin sein im
schnitt habe ich so 300 euro für einen
käufer bezahlt ich kann euch gleich
genau sagen wie viele ich wofür
ausgegeben haben oder vielleicht habe
ich auch schon gesehen drei pakete sind
angekommen und wir machen jetzt erstmal
auf let's go
ich bin wirklich also eigene koffer
brauche in zukunft auf jeden fall nicht
mehr hier zum beispiel schon eine damen
koffer 14 kilo ist er schwer
frauen gehen
immer viel zu viel mit das merke ich
auch in meiner freunde alter wenn ich
mit der verreise ihr könnt euch das
nicht vorstellen wie viel gepäck in den
koffer kommt dann ist ja einfach viel zu
schwer
das habe ich schon zweimal da musste ich
am flughafen drauf sein aber jetzt ist
es ja gut dass frauen so viel mitnehmen
weil wir es hoffentlich sehr viel drin
und make up und so sonnenbrillen
irgendwie sowas das ist ja auch alles
teuer in diesem koffer hier sind hier
auf jeden fall meine größte hoffnung und
dann haben wir noch das letzte paket
check das thema ab eine lufthansa box
ist das original hiermit so lufthansa
paketband checkt gajic megageil leider
freue mich so darauf wie cool oder und
hier kann man das aussehen das war jetzt
der 1769 artikel auf fundsachen
auktion.de kann ich ja mal kurz zu
machen und dann haben wir hier noch
einen kleinen handgepäcks koffer den
habe ich glaube ich sogar für unter 150
euro bekommen und so sieht das denn aus
drei koffer ihr könnt ihr jetzt mal
schätzen glaubt ihr das wird sich lohnen
oder nicht weil 300 euro ist ja auch
schon eine menge
aber wenn ich daran denke wenn ich
verreise und großem koffer mitnehmen da
as safe mehrwert drin als 300 euro
deswegen muss sich ein clown ihr könnt
ja super gerne mal kommentieren was ihr
denkt wie viel wertvoller koffer wenn
ihr einfach so verreist ist das mehr
oder weniger würde mich mal
interessieren schreibt das gerne in die
kommentare und wir machen das zeug es
mal auf jetzt ob ich würde sagen wir
starten einfach noch mit dem koffer den
ich hier am wenigsten werden bekommen
hat und das ist dieser handgepäcks
koffer hier der ungefähr ich glaube acht
kilo soll der wegen stand zumindest so
bei der auktion dabei ist ja auch die
frage kommen diese koffer aus
deutschland oder vielleicht gehört er ja
auch einem afrikaner oder so wer weiß
ich würde sagen ich starte mal mit
dieser tasche
ich habe hier mal okay eigentlich hätte
ich mir auch meine hand für besorgen
habe jetzt nicht dran gedacht indem
fordert taschen hier ist schon mal
nichts
das ist schade aber vielleicht gehe ich
drehe einmal zu euch und wir schauen mal
rein
ok erst mal sieht es so aus auch
sorgfältig gepackt mit polio der hat der
koffer wir halten fest dieser koffer hat
save einer frau gehört ich komme mir
auch schon ein bisschen vorne aber der
bericht auch echt gut der körper
vielleicht bekomme ich ja durch
irgendein hinweis aus welchem land diese
frau kommt und auch sie einen guten
kleines team hatte das ist das erste was
ich hier finde ich glaube hier ist
schminke drin was ist das denn double
serum okay dann haben wir noch eine
online
achtung heilige scheiße ist eine
zahnbürste drin dann haben wir noch eine
bürste und ich zeige euch das mal kurz
so sieht das darin aus zahnpasta und
zahnbürste und hier irgendwelche willich
ohrringe oder sogar ein bisschen eklig
ist das ja nicht
deswegen ist schnell mal wieder alles
hier rein und wir machen das zu dann
geht es weiter mit dieser doku lässig
mit jeans jacke von just be good kenne
ich dich die marke aber sieht so aus als
könnte und marseille secondhand kriegst
du bestimmt noch 30 40 euro für oder ich
wollte jetzt gerade wieder daran riechen
aber deswegen ein bisschen cleverer und
gut so weiter geht es mit diesem diesem
damen bot mir eine damen hose also die
hand auf jeden fall style die ferne
in diesem koffer gerockt hat diesen
äußerungen
in kombination mit der jeansjacke damit
kann man sich auf der straße schon
durchaus sehen lassen so weiter geht
hier mit
das ist ein kleid okay dann haben wir
hier noch so eine bluse alter eine
lacoste bauchtasche oben das ist teuer
oder lacoste bauchtasche hier hinten ein
bisschen ja das sind so schwarze punkte
drauf und da ist auch irgendwas drin was
ist denn da drin einem dekret lipstick
dann haben wir hier schmuck drin ach du
scheiße komplett voll mit schmuck kann
man hier ist auf so einen ring drin und
so ich pack das mal aus ihr seht das
jetzt hier eingeblendet ich kenne mich
mit schmuck aus armaturen überhaupt
nicht aus deswegen schreibt mal was ihr
denkt ist das wertvoll oder ist es
einfach ja gut werden das wertvoll wäre
sie wird das ja kaum in ihren koffer
packen das nimmt man ja im handgepäck
dann mit oder also ich würde mal
vermuten das ist jetzt nicht so viel
wert
aber er hat wegen die 50 60 70 euro wird
das zusammen bestimmt alles kosten denn
wenn ich weiss nicht leute dann müsst
ihr mir helfen schreibt das bitte in die
kommentare und was haben wir hier noch
drin wo immer das recht gut da mussten
wir erst mal hatte ich echt nicht
schlecht jetzt auf jeden fall spielt
diese koffer besitzerin denke das ist so
lustig ne also dass man auch so spaß
wenn es wieder koffer gibt ich mache
einfach weiter damit das macht mir
einfach wegen dem spaß weil man so viel
spaß daran hat es gibt gar nicht nur ums
geldverdienen damit ein paar koffer
auspacken geil okay dann haben wir hier
noch mehr kleidungs sachen das hier ist
zum beispiel von m & s collection
ich denke dass es jetzt alles nicht so
viel wert hier noch so ein kleid dann
wieder eine bluse warum man ärgert sich
bestimmt richtig dass alle ihre schönen
klamotten weg sind wir haben wir eine
stylische sonnenbrille
ach so ja das schließt auch darauf hin
dass diese person ihr könnt das hier
sehr gerne übersehen dass diese person
aus schweden kommen
oder weil schwedische san blas das ist
auf jeden fall der trip noch mehr
kümmern
ich dachte gerade dachte gerade hier
werden gucci zeichen darauf aber nein
das sind denk ich mal kopfhörer
ja das ist auch wieder ein bisschen
eklig haben wir jetzt ein bisschen
schweißt wandten
das sind eng gutt okay sagte nächste die
marke muss ich mal abdecken was sie
kosten gut wenn sie gebraucht sind dann
fällt natürlich der preis extrem nach
unten aber lege ich mir mal hier den
besten bikinis und so sicher und so die
kommentare als ob man ein kleid ja dann
haben junge so zur koffer option das ist
so auch richtig was für so richtig
perverse oder wieder dann so getragene
unterwäsche und so finden wir haben wir
da ein bh oder bikini oder so ist das
immer zum anziehen
ich glaube dass das so ein schlaf hände
oder sowas ein flip flop und wo ist der
zweite hier flip flops von der marke
wenn es habe schuhgröße 9d muss ich euch
auch mal abstecken gut die müsste schon
etwas älter sein diese frau oder jetzt
so wär wär treten so was ich will jetzt
mal sagen die schwedische koffer
besitzerin hiervon ist so zwischen 50
und 60 jahren
damals war vermag sie dann haben wir
hier noch eine hose die ist von zwei war
und hier noch ein badeanzug und hier
dann noch eine junge geht einfach so mit
meinen händen damit ich muss ich meine
hände leute hier haben auf jeden fall
noch eine badehose das war's leider aber
ich würde sagen und haben strich glaube
ich hab mir den koffer 150 irgendwie
zahlt schon geil
also das was da kann man nicht mehr kann
ich räume alles mal sorgfältig zurück
wie ich das auch immer bei mir machen
wenn ich zurück reise okay leute
dann würde ich sagen wir machen mit
diesem koffer weiter der ist von cora
und ich denke mal vielleicht die von
einem franzosen oder einer französin und
kannst du sogar hier verschließen
das ist sicherlich allein der koffer ist
bestimmt schon 100 euro wert da bin ich
jetzt wirklich mal gespannt
und wir machen den mal auf und regen
sagt leuchtet für den habe ich auch 300
euro ausgegeben mit irgendwelchen
auktions gebühren und so alles zusammen
hat 1200 euro gekostet mit diesem
lufthansa vergeht hier fällt mir jetzt
jetzt schon auf der recht nicht so gut
der riecht so als würde diese personen
brauchen
irgendwie habe ich gerade zum leichten
zigaretten geruch in der nase
ach du scheiße was das denn wir haben an
der jacke von 5 cent
das ist wahrscheinlich auch eine
französische marke oder und die heißt
dann sex and also der fünfte sinn oder
so ich hatte lange kein französisch ich
weiß es auch nicht genau
dann haben wir hier eine regenjacke die
qualitativ auf jeden fall nicht schlecht
aus und jetzt wird's hier so ein
bisschen so ein bisschen auf erst fc
nürnberg erste mühlenberg wenn
freundschaft mit 204 haben gut dann ist
das doch nicht vom franzosen oder wir
haben hier einen französischen fc
nürnberg ultra kann auch sein dann geht
es hier weiter mit einer sporthose
also ich glaube diese person ist
fußballfan und männlich das können wir
schon mal festhalten also ich werde
gleich mal in ruhe alle sachen so ein
bisschen ordnen und dann so ein paar
sachen auch mal nachgucken was sie
kosten um euch dann so eine einschätzung
zu geben was man so hier an wert drin
hatten wir da sein muss gestört von
folglich ist okay sagte mir jetzt nichts
dann hier noch mehr fußball sein mag der
ist basketball oder oder der rennt auf
jeden fall vielleicht war das so ein
paar sehr gerne ohne ärmel rumrennt
leute eventuell es kann ja sein dass
jemand der seinen koffer verloren hat
ihn jetzt hier wieder sieht also dass
herzog us werk ein eher passieren ich
meine es ja offensichtlich ein deutscher
eigentlich deswegen fall zu zukunft ich
hoffe du bist mir nicht böse wenn ich
jetzt hier alles so auseinander indem er
ist extrem viel sport zeigt drin alter
der arme der hat gefühlt seiner ganzen
kleiderschrank verloren die haben wir
dann auch mal die hose und irgendwelche
an also alles nur kleidung okay damit
kann ich jetzt nicht so viel anfangen
aber das ist echt viel drin
hier haben wir ja auch eine seite halten
wie lange warst du unterwegs junge
erstmal hier oben ist das eine krawatte
das tue ich schnell wieder rein ich weiß
nicht was das ist will ich auch gar
nicht wissen
ok auch nur klamotten nein oh mein gott
eine ray ban
natürlich bregenz kostet 150 euro neu
gucke ich mir mal an was das für eine
ist okay die ist auf jeden fall schon
getragen hat ziemliche gebrauchsspuren
aber trotzdem mag jetzt nochmal hier
lässt sich auf steht ihm ihr kann ich
damit der war ich schwöre der war auf
malle mit seinen ganzen fußball sachen
so damit dieser sonnenbrille am
ballermann hatte er mal den mädels
hinterher gefüllt
safe packen wir das schnell wieder ein
aber er ist bestimmt so traurig er seine
gute rebellen verloren naja aber gut für
mich ok weiter geht's was haben wir denn
noch ist das eine unterhose
ich hoffe mal dieses ungetragen die
haben wir noch ein gürtel von fossil was
kostet ein ding nicht viel
20 30 euro vielleicht sennheiser
kopfhörer alter geil die sind teuer
also hier haben wir kopfhörer von
sennheiser welche sind das
ich weiß es nicht nur muss ich gleich
mal gucken aber ich kann mir gut
vorstellen dass die 900 euro kosten
könnte
die haben kabel dran ich weiß nicht
genau wie ich auch mal hier zur seite
und weiter geht es hier nicht vor
ich glaube da gut das hier ist ein
kulturbeutel manche menschen das reichen
was ist das für ein kulturbeutel und
machst du den ausgegraben guck mal hier
sind so viel dran und so also da würde
ich erst mal sagen dieser kulturbeutel
gehört jemand und der schaden hat was
haben wir denn da drin alter junge
wissen dreckschwein dass jeder alles
reingeschmissen zahnbürste deshalb
auseinandergefallen
okay da gehe ich gar nicht dran das ist
mir ein bisschen zu eklig
dann haben wir noch komme hier eine
musikbox erstmal was ist das für eine cd
kostet auch 550 euro funktioniert die
noch mal gucken ob die noch angeht da
ist der akku leer aber guck mal das
kabel ist auch direkt dabei nicht
schlecht würde ich mal sagen und hier
haben wir noch ein klappmesser von swiss
aber diese dinger sind glaube ich auch
gar nicht mal so günstig und eine augen
an der marseille auf malle sondern
taucherbrille schwimmbrille hat wurde
jetzt genau was anderes hier haben wir
noch die ok und aha aha auf ganz seriös
unterwegs so grammatik sind hin und
wieder auch teuer oder guckt mal leute
hat sagt da würde mir die stehen solche
direkt selber behalten und ich glaube
das war s dann hier sind noch ganz neue
socken hier haben wir noch ein kabel
okay ja das war's leider also von großen
und ganzen würde ich sagen mit den
ganzen klamotten das ist ja auf jeden
fall mehr wert als 300 euro oder ich
glaube ich weiß ich ganz genau wie viel
ich dafür bezahlt habe aber um die 300
euro müsste es gewesen sein da muss man
halt mal jemanden finden der mir diesen
kleidungsstil denn dieser typ hatte was
anfangen kann also den ersten koffer von
der 50 jährigen schweden fand ich schon
eigentlich meister muss ich sagen aber
es macht auf jeden fall betraf viel spaß
ich habe jetzt mal ein bisschen
recherchiert und das ein oder andere
nachgeschaut in das sicherheit hoffnung
die stadt wie zum beispiel diese
kopfhörer die also das was da drin ist
ist glaube ich gar nicht von sennheiser
dann dieses passes nix wert kostet nur
so acht euro
die lacoste asche von der schwedischen
dame habe ich nicht original heinz
wiedergefunden so eine ähnliche tasche
kostet 985 euro
was haben wir noch da muss ich sagen
einige von den herren klamotten
haben schon wert diese jacke zum
beispiel kostet 100 euro neu hier auch
100 die habe ich gebraucht wird 50
gefunden dass hier drunter habe ich
jetzt nicht nachgeschaut die ganzen
frauen sachen haben jetzt ja doch nicht
so den mega was meistens von zara oder
irgendwie so machen die kosten halt also
das kostet nicht so viel diese hose zum
beispiel kostet im internet 30 europa
trotzdem die menge macht dann auch
irgendwo aber es weiß nichts dabei was
so komplett geisteskrank teuer ist
außerhalb vielleicht noch das weiß ich
nicht
da setze ich alles reinlegen in diesen
teuren goldschmuck konzern habe ich neue
430 gefunden las man noch nach oben da
nicht so etwas öfter machen sollte
einfach verhandler noch wir auch noch
das lufthansa paket deswegen lohnt es
sich sehr zu abonnieren heute ich hab
das alles aufzumachen
bis hierhin erstmal danke fürs zuschauen
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen und
stellte auf jeden fall noch einen
zweiten kanal ob alexa oder gibt es
jetzt jeden tag ein video und da kam
auch diese live koffer optionen wie ich
da so mitgeboten habt könnt ihr dort
sehen als full video war denke ich euch
in der beschreibung danke fürs zuschauen
haut rein und ich pack das jetzt hier
mal sorgfältig wieder zusammen